[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive time then to
see what's making the headlines with the
political editors of the guardian and
the Sun papakura and Harry Cole they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you so to
the eye first of all it says Rishi sunak
has yet to make a decision over whether
to launch a formal ethics inquiry over
the Home Secretary swella bravman's
handling of her speeding offense last
year the guardian carries the findings
of an investigation which heard that
thousands of hospital staff have
reported that they've been sexually
abused while at work the Metro has the
renewed search for Madeleine McCann at a
Portuguese Reservoir near to where she
went missing back in 2007 the sun calls
the situation the riddle of the lake
similarly here is the mirror the
headline muddy cops search Lake
the guardian the financial times rather
reports on Facebook's parent company
meta being fined more than a billion
pounds by the eu's Privacy regulator
over how it handled users data and the
times leading on government plans to cut
NHS waiting lists by encouraging
patients to use the NHS app to choose
treatment in private hospitals well
quick reminder don't forget to scan that
QR code that you'll see on screen during
the program and you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's newspapers
while you watch us before we listen and
get more from Pippa and Harry let us
bring you some breaking news we're just
getting Sky News understands that
Dominic Robb will stand down as an MP at
the next lesson he of course MP4 Isha
and Walton since 2010 he had recently
held the post of Deputy Prime Minister
and Justice secretary forced to stand
down over bullying allegations which he
disputed but previously he had been
brexit secretary and then foreign
secretary under which he oversaw and was
criticized for the pull-out from
Afghanistan so our understanding is that
Mr Rob will not stand as an MP at the
next general election well let's head to
Our Guest then and get more on that
um Harry I don't suppose this comes as
too much of a surprise for people
foreign
no I don't think so look at the um look
at the local lib Dems in his patch it
was a tight seat anyway he only just
scraped back a couple of times the last
few many elections we've had of late
um obviously incredibly disillusioned uh
figure from Deputy Prime Minister to
back bencher to now XM soon to be XMP
whenever the election comes I think um
it was no surprise
um to people who who've seen Dominic
Robb of late spoken from the last month
he does feel very very poorly treated I
think
um by not only not necessarily the Prime
Minister but um certainly
um left-wing activists trade unions like
the FDA who did you know did coordinate
a lot of complaints that turned out not
to have been upheld they're what he does
feel there was a bit of a a Witch Hunt
against him one complaint was upheld
which was a very senior official who had
been caught red-handed trying to
undermine brexit negotiations
um and you know it was slightly more
complicated than the sort of image of a
workplace bully that was allowed to sort
of propagate for for months and months
so no surprise what you see him to throw
in the towel and um I suspect he'll um
yeah didn't fancy another five years on
the back benches a Pippa a lot of
shaking of head there um you explained
your position
well like me with Harry that the lib
Dems were snapping at Dominic Robb's
heels he had a majority of just over 2
000 in 2019 compared to a majority of 23
000 two years before that so he looks
set to lose the election he also in his
letter to his constituency chairman
cites and pressure of his job over many
years on his young family he's got two
sons I think we're just eight and ten as
a consideration many politicians share
but I'm afraid his characterization of
the Dominic Dominic Rob bullying though
I think is uh slightly should we say
one-sided to say it was too um just that
two uh complaints were upheld is not the
case one of those complaints was was
several and but more than several a
number of civil servants
um Junior ones and Senior ones at the
ministry of Justice it was a it wasn't
the group complaint which wasn't upheld
it was the it was the individual ones
and I think Adam Tolley because he was
the the um KC that was carrying out the
investigation uh called for about
arranged by Rishi sinak into those
allegations over for several months
because he came to the conclusion that
he wanted to protect the anonymity of
the civil servants because obviously
they don't have a public voice and
indeed the witnesses he left out a lot
of detail of the report but we reported
a lot of these stories and some of the
detail was incredibly harrowing about
how he treated civil servants and how he
made them feel including in one case
pushing somebody to the brink of suicide
which is a very serious allegation and
another of the complaints which wasn't
upheld from his time back in dexu uh
when he was briefly brexit secretary was
only not uh basically totally didn't
come to judgment either way because he
said it was so uh long ago so I think to
say that he's been hard done by and it
was some civil service
is very much what dominic Robb and his
supporters would like you to say I think
yeah
he feels hard I said he feels hard done
by anyone who's spoken to him said this
is how
it was badly treated yeah okay and I
think some in that group complaint had
actually accepted he hadn't actually had
much interaction with him so you know
that fed it to him
gotcha anyway he is one as we know of a
number of resignations from the sunac
government
um he'll be hoping to hold on to Suleman
one imagines
um so the guardian if we kick off with
that and might as well stay with you
pepper on this if you don't mind
um the most senior civil servant in the
home office was made aware of
allegations that swella bravman wanted
to help in dealing with a speeding fine
so explain the significance of that then
right so I mean it's really interesting
because uh this story obviously broke on
Saturday afternoon and the expectation I
think when people came back to
Westminster today was and of course
Rishi sinach was flying back from Japan
was that he would uh consult with his
ethics advisor
um Laurie Magnus and that he would
probably ask him to investigate this
these claims
um and of course that hasn't that hasn't
happened today
um I think you know Carlson back to
dominate Rob where she's like took a
couple of days there as well number 10
suggest that he wants to see to once for
the due process he wants to be seen to
be doing
um things the right way so he's
obviously taking time to find out
himself what the facts were before he
asks Laurie Magnus to to investigate if
indeed he does do that
um uh so this story in the guardian is
is a suggestion that the civil servant
who was
um who was asked by Sola bravaman to
arrange
um according to the claims to arrange
um uh private a bespoke driving
awareness course um was understood that
it was that it was potentially a breach
of the code that certainly shouldn't be
something that they should be asked to
do and reported that up to
um to Matthew rycroft as the permanent
secretary the most senior official in
the department and what it does I think
is raise the question about whether
other senior officials
um or indeed other other senior
politicians knew about these allegations
which of course all happened back in
September even though they only just
came out now so it's question marks
about who knew what and when
um what I guess while we wait to see
what Richardson exercise to do in terms
of an Ethics investigation into the
allegations yes and that idea of waiting
again makes the front page of the eye
Harry says no I know Jacob we smog was
suggesting that
um you know celebrities can have private
um speeding hearings or um you know the
lesson rather than taking the three
points if she'd asked anybody else would
it have been all right for her to ask or
was it just plain wrong on every level
that's what the number of this comes
down to she's bringing up a lawyer and
said can I can you organize me a private
um a private meeting um Mr loophole one
of the one of the lawyers one of the
sort of driving lawyers has come out in
public he said he's organized loads of
VIP uh one-on-one meetings there's no
there's a question of whether it's a bad
look that the the homes actually didn't
want to sort of mingle with the public
so to speak but then you know her
Defenders are saying we've got to take
into security concerns so when she did
raise in the office and no one's dying
that she did raise it in the office and
say look how could I do this do I kind
of is there a chance I can do this
one-on-one
um it looks like the Civil Service it
went into the Civil Service machine I
think it reached all as far as the
cabinet office before it came back and
said actually no this isn't really
something the Civil Service can help you
with now the question of the nub of this
issue is is did her asking her private
office for advice
constitute a breach of the ministerial
code now that's what I think the delay
in in the ethics advisor and the prime
minister is is coming down to is is that
a breach that is worthy of an
investigation if it is a breach is it
was he just you know sort of looking at
her different options ultimately she
didn't she didn't do this so I suspect
it feels like the longer this goes on it
felt a change in mood tonight that
actually it feels like perhaps we should
see that we saw him saw him in the
Commons uh sweater braveman and kind of
supportively on the back when he arrived
in the Commons is he actually thinking
but perhaps this has been a little bit
overblown he wants to see the paper
trail he wants to know if things were
done in the right way and actually maybe
there won't be the investigation that
that the opposition are clamoring for
and actually you know because nothing
nothing actually came of it
um whether this really is a breach so I
suspect we'll know very early tomorrow
morning yes I've done nothing on tour
doesn't mean I didn't try to do
something Untold I suppose her critics
is it is I think is the question I think
you know is it a reward to say actually
is there a way as the Home Secretary
with my security detail that I can go to
a meeting one-on-one it's it's whether
it's whether you know no one's
suggesting that she tried to avoid doing
paying the fine or doing the course you
know if she'd be trying to get out the
course and pay the fine obviously that's
untoward but I haven't seen any evidence
yet of anyone actually suggesting that
she tried to avoid some form of
punishment which is either the course or
the points
go for it pepper I honestly I can see
your itching
it's obviously not um I was absolutely
right it's not suggesting that she was
trying to avoid it but the point is the
ministerial code is quite clear about
either either a parent or actual
conflicts um and that and that ministers
need to take need to keep their public
duties apart from their private lives so
that means the ministers can't for
example ask their civil servants to
arrange their Tesco shopping to be
delivered or their kids to be picked up
from school or indeed to sort out um
Arrangement arrangea uh speeding
awareness course and and I think what it
comes down to is did she ask them for
advice or did she direct them as some of
the claims suggest did she direct them
to actually arrange that uh arrange that
course and I think I suspect that's what
will come down to ultimately but
regardless it does feel like on the on
the Lesser end the lower end if you like
of potential breaches and under the new
rules it's not just okay piece of sort
of a binary case of either administrator
and guilty and they're sacked or they're
not found guilty and they stay in post
there's a range of sanctions available
to the Prime Minister including things
like public apology or docking a bit of
the ministry or salary and it feels
likely that if this investigation goes
forwards and if and there's lots of this
here I understand that
um that she's found to breach the code
that we wouldn't necessarily even in
that case expect her to go yes indeed
well actually the eye in its a few
paragraphs on it it's front page says
that bravman is picking fights and
looking for an excuse to get sacked as
new party divisions break into the open
the kind of suggestion was that that's
what happened last time she resigned
Harry
well that was a a crazy time for
everyone which if anyone wants to know
exactly what happened there they should
buy my book I've got to get a plug in
there
clearly clearly a controversial figure
you know but I don't think actually
reality if you see if you think why
Richardson bought it back just 10 days
after she was sacked by Liz truss she
was her coming over to Richie sunac and
pulling out the race and saying it's got
to be rishy basically it's killed Boris
Johnson's hopes of come back uh last
October stone dead so you know she is a
powerful figure on the right she is a
leadership Contender she was almost
certainly going to be one of the if
notorious lose the election one of the
major candidates for the to be the
leader of the opposition so you know
politically it's a headache for sudak as
well she may be itching for a fight but
I'm not saying she's unsackable and if I
do say that she'll probably get fired
tomorrow but you know you've got to look
at where sunak is he is not in a great
position at the moment yes he's got the
sort of party rump of MPS and ministers
behind him but the right wing of the
party are cross they are agitating they
want more Vision they want tax cuts they
want something done about migration all
building up to Thursday when there's
this great Crescendo of the the
government's failure on immigration and
all the promises laid bare before
everyone's eyes Rishi sunak isn't going
to want to take that by himself he's
going to want to Serena braveman there
is a bit of a human shield to keep the
right wing of his party happy so it's
much stronger position than people on
Twitter would would have you believe
well I mean you say a failure of
government policy but are we actually
being able to send our pigs to the
abattoir because he brought an abattoir
workers and actually staff our Care
Homes because they brought in Care Home
workers so that's what people will be
analyzing on Thursday when they see the
migration workers and the sort of
skilled workers who've come in on that
at I'm just going to revert to the Daily
Telegraph paper on the front page
they've got the Rob story there they say
the Daily Telegraph has seen an exchange
of letters between the former deputy
prime minister and the chairman of his
local conservative Association
explaining his decision Mr Robb wrote
the letter dated last Friday I have
become increasingly concerned over the
last few years about the pressure the
job has placed on my young family his
sons Peter and Joshua as you said age 10
and 8 respectively are points you've
already made but the telegraph has that
story on its front page we'll welcome
back you're watching the Press preview
with me once again Pippa crew and Harry
Cole from the guardian and the sun
welcome back to both of you
um so big day in terms of NHS and labor
Pippa my NHS reforms will cut the
biggest Killers within a decade he's
talking about heart disease cancer
suicide as well but some big pledges I
don't know what money he's talking about
and some very familiar looking targets
which were very Blair right I thought
listening to them
well they won't just play right they
were they're Tory targets I mean there's
a series of five targets about ranging
from things like um any waiting times to
ambulance weights to cancer referrals
which have been proposed by the
government
um and which Libra has said that they
would deliver in the first five years of
the labor government
um prompting some sort of skepticism as
to whether they're actually deliverable
deliverable but I think that skepticism
really just goes so goes far to show
um what sort of lack of faith people
have in in government running the NHS at
the moment given it's um it's really uh
been honest in many cases it's on its
knees I can caveat that with the fact
that hospitals GPS and and other uh NHS
providers offer an incredible service
despite the pressures that they face on
um on Workforce and and other and other
issues but yes this is one of cure
starma's five missions which he is
setting out we've already had let me get
this right crime the economy and
education and I think we've got
um uh climate still to come health is
obviously a big one NHS is often at the
top of the list of Buddha's concerns
coming up to an election and this is not
a sort of a policy this is not their
policy proposals in their entirety on
the NHS this is supposed to be sort of
like the work underpinning what will
then be set out at the Autumn conference
then ahead of an election in a Manifesto
next year but what Kirsten was unable to
do today in any of the broadcast
interviews that he did this morning and
indeed in the questions after this event
that you've you're picturing there was
to to set out explicitly how some of
these changes would be funded I think
the closest we got to it was him
acknowledging in an interview beforehand
that him signaling that the word that
labor government would put more funding
into the NHS in England they've talked a
lot about wanting to reform it but they
have acknowledged and he said and that
yes he'd his uh his uh he was asked
about where he put his money where his
mouth is on this and he said yes money
is part of the answer and the NHS has
always funded better funded under Libra
so that was a step forward from where we
got to where we've been before and that
he's at least saying he's acknowledging
that it will require some cash what he's
not yet doing is setting out in its
entirety where that money would come
from there's a few specific examples
like you know more doctors and nurses
paid for by
um paid for by scrapping the non-dom tax
and so on but um I think there'll be an
expectation from the electorate that he
he does set up more detail they say
they're going to do that let's see but
it's so key to vote of trust in whether
government's future governments um are
likely to be able to deliver
um on on some of the policies like we
saw today yeah okay um very interesting
uh quick 30 seconds Financial Times
talking about meta we finally found out
what gdpr does apart from makers go
except all cookies endlessly at Harry
yeah I'm pretty hefty whacking great
find there which I think
um you know I'm one of the people that
gives the uh EU its fair amount of stick
over the years but you know this is
clearly something globally that
um lots of people have uh uh you know
are incredibly concerned about our
Online safety bill in the UK is you know
somewhere bouncing around I think in the
House of Commons House of Lords at the
moment clampdowns on sort of the the
tech Giants are coming and this is where
the EU can use its heft you know that
matter probably the most famous one of
the most famous and biggest companies in
the world has hit a wall here I suspect
there'll be loads of legal wranglings
around it but it's certainly a good sign
of a show of intention that you know
these companies cannot be bigger than
countries and bigger than bigger than
you know governments and need to be
brought to Hill from time to time so
yeah good on them okay Harry Pippa thank
you both very much indeed